what's a full podcast what's our full
podcast with Rodrigo Tori right here man
listo they're quiet over there
Aaron rower they're over there no new
keyboard a new board intern right here
learning learning those skills the ropes
the ropes did she have for a camera for
you and the secretary right here the new
sound board awesome she's coming here
for the first take wife you two worth it
yeah what's up what's up fool we're
right here man everybody talking about
can't even see nothing what are you
talking about everybody give everybody
microphone one everybody microphone it's
a microphone the door somebody I'm
looking for the the mail
what's up boo we just got back from
where we get back from Coachella
Coachella we're in Cochella spotlight 29
man there were no time to do nothing
like doing a gig with your dad for real
because they picked us up and it was
like 30 minutes away
yeah but I'm you what you wanted to do
something you're back in your hotel room
boy man we're gonna drive her back even
those other two little fools didn't want
to go back it was far
yeah it was a trip yeah it was like a
resort I never been to that resort yep
never did never golf course
dude last time I went there was in was
it 2006 but I had my reunion high school
reunion it was there 10 years I was it
was up the street at the little resort
thing there's like a bunch of LaQuinta
yeah it was in that little city right
there right there on that off that
Street Bob Hope Drive it's all golf
courses huh oh yeah in hotels and like
you know spas or whatever if you're
walking around the street I mean you
left your job you got stranded huh yeah
that was there you see those tweakers
driving in have to talk about bad about
that area but every time I've been there
I've seen a lot of tweakers yeah like a
desert palm desert spring hot springs
well I went to a 7-eleven one time
nearby a hotel we were standing just to
get stuff we saw everybody bro man in
danger when you show up at 2:00 in the
morning to a 7-eleven and you see 40
year olds and BMX bicycle all right
they're super big really very this guy
you know his wife probably hit the keys
to the car so he took his son's bike to
go see what happens
I probably doesn't know where to buy
meth so he's gonna hit her 70 levels of
somebody all those crazy or name so
always the spots right there do like
Pendleton style bro I've never seen
treated with the penalty penalty but you
know that I buy the good bits a flannel
pajamas shirt that's always dangerous
man 40 rows it'd be a mix up to no good
and we're slaughters favorite 12 that we
Marty Moreno is having here some his
dumb heart fest whatever it's called
yeah be their favorite 12 it's gonna be
at harvilles right in Long Beach so
there you go man there's their child
yeah gave I gave bubbles a ride to the
airport tomorrow yeah think about moving
here then I've seen all these people
right here looking like zombies invited
me of Hayward well they're not people
waiting at the waiting for waiting for
the meeting greet at the
Murch yeah well a lot of people were
asking dude and so I just told him idea
listen dude get your merchandise he's
probably gonna roll out at the end he's
gonna wait for it to die down all right
that's why you have those dudes that
came out of nowhere not when you first
showed up come on I know where Bob Joey
I saw some guy and I think a photo with
me and then like as soon as he saw that
security guard over there by leading
everybody out that foot went under the
rope to ropes to catch our Larry bubbles
guard it up ah yeah man get the line
moving ma'am thank you
they had the NDI washers and that
started the whole thing dude cuz one
then another one came over and then
another one came on my listen dude I
can't okay I'm get them okay do my job I
can't just give you a shirt okay the bus
is a lot of killers are a lot of killers
right where they buried pools in the
desert dogs there are some guys there
man who you could tell they they bout to
wait ticket for everybody oh hell yeah I
got a whole cans at these shows man like
I know that these shows a lot of real
estate fools or or car salesmen show up
sleazeball with nothing but their fans
but they shouldn't show up I bring other
ten friends who are gonna invest in
something guys were part of these games
and invest in a timeshare out there yeah
dude but other people buzz dude wanted a
party dog party hard yeah yeah but that
time I was there I was with Bill Bellamy
but before that I was with Paul
Rodriguez and I remember about a good a
steak at that casino right there at
spotlight oh yeah I was good man steak
and lobster
after the show we left that show I went
to morongo to gamble are you serious
yeah well that's pretty close right what
30 minutes yeah we were to gamble and
then after we gamble we ate up don't we
a part we do we eat we gave they have a
fat burgers there mm-hmm so I have a
little fat burger there before we leave
with the little egg on top knowing that
what you like no but I remember today
were hanging out with [ __ ] a chum
lotta
he's out with the little egg on top back
in the day when you see numero uno pizza
dog with
treinen Vinnie dogs nobody would know I
like that pizza my tail like pure butter
the crust oh my god there's already
cheese on the pizza
we're at top of each other Tommy John
he's to live in a little apartment
studio Matt forgot where I was sitting
at one time it was the other day they
made a beam pour it on my bed my pillows
how about what he showed us was modeling
videos first came to California right
yeah get the modeling from Detroit jump
on anything huh
oh my god this will did the whole like
walk down the aisle thing and came back
and did the lips and everything dude in
a suit fool jheri curl now turn around
you try anything to make money in the
beginning man whoever denied even said
it man he chose doing or self-defense
videos
[Laughter]
he made self-defense videos like who's
gonna buy these like what like somebody
ran up on him and he did a cross do it
like in case of an attack you do this in
case of a hug from Zapata did it work
for that for now I don't know he ever
made it okay but he did make a movie
though hey cuz when I first started I
told that fool he was the haha trying to
convince me to do comedy boot camp dog
come on just started off forty bucks and
that's the first you know your
introductory course I was like damn this
is a five hundred dollar course dog and
got five yeah got five was so fool man I
don't know if you had know or listeners
here about um I did a couple of podcasts
in the last month I want to go listen to
him I don't know Joey cocoa tears the
Churchill was happening check that out I
was on this podcast with Martin Marshall
Rizzo
Johnny rocket so yeah man that that
party should be called our next victim
but it's called um
time with Nick Johnny and Martin time
would make Johnny Martin but what
bulletin today
we took about comedy we talked about
people getting upset on social media we
talked about the first comedy books I
ever read
they helped me do comedy give me any
books on company or just without it no I
do what I used to do was a Rida it's
called the started stand-up comedy I
used to go to the library at a cus it's
an arena and it'll tell you where
everybody perform it go went back all
the way dude Shelley Berman dude or
Richard Pryor part Rodriguez was in it
dude wasn't in with a book it was called
the stars of stand-up comedy Howie
Mandel everybody that made it well it'll
work it was a biography and it'll tell
you no said everywhere this guy started
how he started everything it was a lot
of aspects not just a history of it
that's the only thing I ever read and
there was a little um there's a it's how
to be funny is that yeah how to be funny
right funny and make funny I switched to
the to the to the part where said how to
write a joke and had a Rodney
Dangerfield yeah one-liner and how he's
all this is the premise premise and the
punch so it's in threes premise premise
punch and they don't tell you like do
your own huh yeah yeah so that's the
only thing I've ever did and I used to
watch The Tonight Show the comedian's it
would go on there in the monologue yeah
my gym paren did the one I read and I
had the same thing and I'm Steve Allen
okay and then the ones about how to
write how to write jokes for a certain
way but that but these boys morning for
comedy writers huh yeah dude cuz it's
all format dude format ha ha ha you know
I mean it's like it's like when you're
watching a movie and you're II know is
gonna happen right that's what if you if
you have any net for comedy that's I
knew I was funny but I just need a
format those books really help me okay
and that's just a some paper giorgia
said that I help him but I help them
yeah it does do that this is what would
it how does it help you dude 10 years
down the line you're doing something
full in a certain way you didn't know
how to do and it comes out of that for
ya that's what I think it helps you if
you don't like do it like like textbook
style and then it'll slowly go into your
what you're doing that's how I help me
who make Guerra broke down a tic-tac-toe
bro
[Laughter]
worse go wrong
no tic-tac-toe all right this word
doesn't eat that or worse depend on no
bro I thought the tic-tac-toe well you
know one two three four five six seven
eight nine squares so I thought that a
tic-tac-toe with nine the nine squares
and I thought that um in each square you
write down your fireman is set so
dentists will be the first square and
relationship will be the second sex will
be the third so five ten fifteen minutes
right there so I thought that's how I'll
square the tic-tac-toe was everyone with
a box like a category relationships
parents current events so keep going
that's it oh so that's what how you
thought how down him okay so wrong all
wrong Nick gear us Nick Garrett said
that the tic-tac-toe is um you write
down a tic-tac-toe and then um so you
write down in the middle you write down
dogs and then over here on square one
you write down what type of dogs that
you wha wah blah blah blah then you
write right here stuff like um you see
people with dog loners so you pretty
much do some brainstorming things right
yeah it's a brainstorming yeah squeeze
everything out of that premise so me
what I what I learned was rectangles cuz
you show me team paren was you write
down dogs and feel rank Jones for Johnny
Carson here right dogs then over here
here write down
Chihuahua Saint Bernard whatever said
over here write down like people who own
dogs
losers hipsters Asian couple whatever
you know my hair you seen what people
have done with dogs to go for walks eat
them whatever then over here you're
right down idea you come up with with
other everything you wrote down which
broke down one time you had a little
communist in your all you break broke
everything down in subjects subjects and
uh just to make it easier dog and then
you can just feed off that yeah but are
that for told me about like deal chomp
is used to regulate on these Texas
comedians back in the
cuz he nobody made it that far nobody
was a headliner so he would go over
there and check all those fools and kind
of be like really like like hard up on
him little hard we could breasts are
bright but isn't the goal to have a long
set to have a full set because your way
would give you 45 minutes yeah that was
way gives you one long joke about us
yeah so my will my the way I thought
about it we'll see I had it all wrong
so I came up with the next level
tic-tac-toe yours is more useful because
what you're working on five minutes you
could do it any way you want right cuz I
that's the whole trick the whole thing
he should say I just wrote a new 45 man
don't shoot nobody
so yeah matter so he broke it down so he
broke it down brothel area so they're
dumb so they're much of rhythm I love
you do a circle right and you write dogs
and over here you write you why why do
line like a cloud yeah that's like
original English class
so same thing it's the same [ __ ] if I
said a joke because I know what man I
don't know why but when I told you I
took journalism with Miss Powell Miss
Powell in East LA college what you learn
there man we to brainstorm everyday do
like every morning every class like miss
power say um she would say just say the
car the iran-contra deal right there
boom so right there man you gotta write
out a whole story about it what you know
or what you heard brainstorming even if
you didn't know stuff you gonna run a
ring in you know Oliver North Oliver
North whatever whatever you thought so
you do like you brainstorm and then um
you just turn it in and then what you
say stop and if you have half a page
whatever I never wrote it I mean no
writing no right bringing stormy right
writing okay in the full sentence in
like OK ROCK contra you know Oliver
noise whatever and then but it'll be
like another won't be loved
so you write a will be loved but every
day every time we went there it was just
something different with all my
journalism
not in that class it was two idiots I
want to punch this [ __ ] start to
many journal is a movie throw oh my god
you know Salvador too much just prove a
dress bro like with like combat gear
dawg whoa yeah and they have a camera
dog who whatever to promote to
photography so they're taking
photography and journalism those are
enough who had most games bro yellow no
pass bro heritage bro they they were
Latinos wrong oh militant ones away no
they're a militant broads so they just
out like they had the whole gear to go
out in the field yeah brutally they had
a I didn't need it was a backpack in
there with it was a typewriter size but
they were dressed like they were doing a
story in Vietnam bro photojournalist
unleash like don't shoot me I'm with
oppressed but they're paparazzo is
paparazzi people don't understand that
these people don't work for anybody
they're freelancing they're like a
Nightcrawler right yeah they're just
trying to get a good shot that they
could sell if you look at them they'll
have those like fishing jackets but
that's who paparazzi is it's not anybody
who's officially right you can make some
bucks if you get some like exclusive
stuff right good you could but it just
like people come down on paparazzi but
there really is no upper level to
complain to you know like it's a
free-for-all pretty much like you've
done red carpets and you don't know who
half those people are that outlets are
some of them are sticking a cellphone in
your face it's like when we went to the
way awards three of those little ladies
they look like they were hired by
somebody and sent there to just get a
clip get a clip of everybody who came by
was so fool ass Friday man
Thursday we went to the premiere of den
of thieves with Gerard Butler and O'Shea
Jackson jr. jr. and a bunch of other
people that I'll never see again to
another movie and go hey that's a guy
from den of thieves that redneck guy
yeah the only other dude I was a
mastermind of the ball hit dude I've
seen the movie the bad guy he's good
though played a villain dude I could do
like that but that's the first time I
seen him at the movie made 14 million
are you serious number three Oh
but yeah I've seen a lot of if I was if
I was it like in seventh grade I
probably would've thought of the best
movie ever you're blown away yeah but
now that I know what the movie is about
and moving him plot-wise than it makes
then I feel like they could have chunk
of it that was missing the chunk of how
you get a human being into the Federal
Reserve yeah bro what that is this
impossible right and they would have
found it and understand why they still
that armored truck well it was a way to
get into the federal law okay that a do
you see those two fools that were in
front of those hardcore actor fools they
were criticizing the movie the whole
time dog in this yeah they were right
below us dude took my left nerves right
oh dude yeah man so what's up Tito Ortiz
boy oh dude how was that black food
talking brother oh boy did he was cool
in the beginning to do but he stopped as
soon as it started remember dude that a
producer guy was out there talking and
it took us 14 years and this and that
and that brother just started good
speech 14 years it took this den of day
to be made man so and it's only 14 years
man hey Jackson starting with your six
[Laughter]
talk about the process of writing we're
the red carpet people we were in there I
was on the red carpet people are taking
photos of me asking me questions I don't
know who the people were
in the back you see like a like a
Halloween right behind me over in the
camera
it looks funny of you if you actually
buy the footage but a funny man there
was a guy that I swear to God I thought
I was Seth MacFarlane I'm family oh my
god and then he looked just like him
and then we wrote jingo ask me a brother
that's on the husband I said no man it's
textbook for Lin phoo I I might be blind
or some so a neighbor told you go brush
under Jessica no Feeny
but he was a producer though that's who
that boy was he went on stage and I
totally bugged him too because it was a
lady talking to him another oh he's off
alright I didn't know that was some fool
our guest is here below
Tom Rhodes broke the legend which is him
right now but he is here what's up my
brother all the way totally BAM stirred
Rodrigo I brought you guys some cookies
from Holland oh it's a good idea to eat
cookies on well these cookies right here
are the waffles with a caramel inside
yes Starbucks it cost like the big ones
the car those [ __ ] three bucks and
Amsterdam
three bucks but I can get two of those
the bags probably tastes better than in
Amsterdam in the markets they'll sell
them fresh like I don't have a dude's
like cooking them they're like 50 cents
amazing little bit of the crispy as you
can get from the cookie what's up fool
wonderful the thing is cracking the food
scene karim
seemed he seen quitting get him guitar
player guitar player he was on the audio
podcast for one and two I managed to
bury cats
we're at at the kilowatts hey boss
killer well it was like the comedian
night out bro
Sunday night fraser-smith had everybody
ever giving him a guest spot brought in
the show nobody on one room it was me a
Ruben Park Steve Wilson I think Freddy I
think um Mary case went up before me and
the guy the real guy from disaster movie
art Bonilla red Vince Ferragamo from the
Rams and let's close it out sleeping in
her car
Tania strata is that really came
straight from the set have you ever done
Barry casas podcast yeah he always tries
to go like a layer deep early what was
the last time you cry or do you have the
definition of a comedian this is the guy
here undeniable with a capital u I've
always wanted to represent this guy even
when I had Dave Chappelle I was on top
of the world and I still wanted some Tom
Rhodes
it's a horrible impression but never but
very accurate what's up fool upcoming
show January 27 where my my mrs.
Doubtfire doubtful glasses vampire
generally 7 to saneras honest sorry to
casino at the other democracy no
February 1st through 3rd Naples Florida
after her comedy club with captain Brian
Ryan that's a good room that's not fair
11 Oakland California Paramount Theater
part of a big show with DeRay Davis
preacher loss and Bruce Bruce fortunate
beamster whatever other guy they can
find Oakland he's gonna be 13 14 that's
right Valentine's Day Corpus Christi
Texas an American Bank Center with
Raymond Ulta that's right Raymond Ulta
then
we're showing up it's Raiders vs.
Cowboys or LA we gotta do a little
sketch with him bro awesome crazy Raider
fans Clash of the Titans clash of the
titans bro
make it happen Raven or that what's up
ooh February 22nd Lemoore California at
tachi Casino Resort favorite 23rd
let's take in the banner at Treasure
Island Casino favorite 24th Rochester
Washington lucky casino who's gonna be
on the show with me I'll tell you who
when you go Torres and Larry Bobo's
brown man the happiest day of my life
take it so now I see up for the two
lieutenants shows March 23rd at the Nova
Theatre in downtown LA we sold about
half of the place or so far so hurry up
lots more days
check out Philippe world.com tour for
our show dates and tickets well Gino
what you got coming I'll be on the road
with you and we got a new yeah man
episode that dropped yesterday so please
check it out
Tyrone what's on an hour later yeah both
right this table rows people in the top
row show this Monday January 29th I'll
be at the théâtre de louvre in paris
france I'm sure you got lots of
listeners and terrorists guys come on
February 7th through the 10th I'll be at
the punchline in San Francisco and
February 22nd to the 25th albeit side
splitters in Tampa and I have a brand
new album on iTunes called all hey
laughter get it in you get it people all
hell laughter yeah man what's up bro
Ginga what you got
chillin man how much you weigh now 285
haha 280 or I'll give you the real way
to 79 Bert Kreischer and Tom and Tom
Segura they get together Duluth way bro
you and I get together
oops long so I'm starting my push-up
regiment 26 dog my wife is pushing me to
lose weight she's got me exercising
she's into this Nike Training stuff
where there's like a nap and I tried it
twice
I would I would rather throw myself in
front of a truck when around Donald
Trump was 235 even as doctors a liar
that's guys 275 but beginnings bad from
the bottom of your foot will make you
grow an inch heavier than regular way
what's the love you ever worked out will
you go read your mail you say you know
you worked our hard core pray about six
months yeah we probably don't play
basketball I notice your those days of
playing every day and that was all what
spring in the summer yeah just stop I
know about ten years ago I was doing
this become yoga where you do it in a
room that's a hundred degrees it's
really easy cause it's kind of
stretching and you don't have to you
know if there's like a position you
can't do you don't have to do it and I
would get with like the overweight
housewives in the back row and try and
like blend in and just you know not draw
any attention to myself and you know I
thought it was good the heat and the
sweating and I really like extreme heat
but it's expensive my wife hates it she
won't allow me to do it anymore
and I enjoy in the gym in my building
there's a treadmill and it's got a
little TV on it and it's got like nine
walks around the world I don't know how
they filmed it with like a drone or
sometimes I'm like one of them are like
two of them are in New Zealand and I did
the New Zealand Comedy Festival a few
years ago I'm one of them is downtown
Auckland so like when I on the rare
occasion that I'll walk on the treadmill
I'm walking around New Zealand it's kind
of cool the Reno's leaving though yeah
because it's like downtown and I was
downtown a few years ago so my gosh it I
mean I ate at that Burger King that yoga
thing though what would you go inside
the building yeah sometimes I'll be like
here all over America and they're all
over the world but the guy had a sex
scandal that guy so it's not called
Bikram anymore sorry but a lot of his
yeah everybody's going down but it a lot
of his instructors and stuff sued him
and apparently a lot of places it's just
called hot yo it is really like in Texas
or Arizona Florida you can get them for
like 15
but California it's like ridiculous but
the rumors filled up with heat so it's
kind of good so I mean even though you
if you can't I could never do the poses
very well but you're just put on my
hoodie go in Tobey Hicks room 86 Tommy
Hicks is a comedian he always has room
at like 86 but I've noticed every
brother I have ever came like that I
have his friend their houses are always
hot do these cold man we never had heat
Mansell or a/c so I really was in
trouble
really I mean I grew up in Florida and
my family was mildly impoverished and my
father had this one hundred degree
air-conditioning rule in our house I
swear to God we could not turn on the
air-conditioner unless it was 100
degrees or hotter and June and July
would suck you'd be teetering in 9899
everyone on the carpet just like that I
can't move that's not at all because
once they hit 200 degrees outside but
Tonica cools off inside the 86
it'll never get to 71 you definitely
like one fan and the family taking turns
sitting in front of it was Bertil dude
the first house we moved into they had
an AC unit my dad clip that [ __ ] you
broke the wires like I don't know what
live with AC would our school never had
one arson that's why I like to go to
school because we had AC
unless your classes were one of the
bungalows yeah that's a lot of those one
of those mobile units mobile homes
it's funny how school got big huh my
school started I was a building then all
of a sudden the all the playground
bungalows they keep adding more rules
and more rooms I had to go to summer
school every year and and I grew up in
Florida and so they would handle a small
town outside of Orlando called Oviedo
it was a it was a Oba dough it's named
after a city in Spain a tiny little
citrus farming village when I grew up
there but they would retar the roof in
the summer and so that smelt like you'll
see like the the on the like a pickup
truck pulling one of those little
trailers are the black that smell always
reminds me of summer school I just I
could just I can feel getting smacked on
the back of the head every time I smell
I don't know Go Go blackjack licorice
licorice
so he's trying wouldn't you want to be a
comedian
I will reading from where that I'm some
comic brought you up on stage yeah my my
family is originally from Washington DC
DC my chocolate a my yeah I was born in
South East hospital I was like my and my
parents met at Anacostia high school
like it couldn't be more mcgrann
slimming there once upon a time but now
it's like hardcore DC ghetto but my
father
Richard Pryor loves stand-up comedy and
my uncle did open mic nights for one
year and I was local I was I was 11
years old Bob Ryan Bob right coming up
next
Uncle Bob Uncle Bob and my dad took me
to see him and I was 11 years old we
walk in the front door is next to the
entrances next to the stage and the the
club was packed the show was already
going on I remember just everybody
smoking and you know multi-ethnic people
in the audience it just seemed like
[ __ ] magical place and the comedian on
stage pulled me on stage because I was
wearing a Washington Redskins jacket and
he interviewed me like I was the coach
of the Redskins and I was 11 and I just
gave little little kid don't be one more
dancers no yes but I'll never forget
standing on that stage seeing all those
happy people with their heads thrown
back and laughter and and that moment
changed my life from that moment on I
never wanted to do anything else other
than be a stand-up comedian so then I
started when I was 17 with a fig well so
you started stealing uncles lap huh I
started my first show ever was that a
from a black fraternity at cus assembly
no it was it was a town show got third
place a singer and a drummer beat me
damn but they also had two comedians I
remember like I was an open mic in San
Bernardino like La Puente and it was a
comedian there doing comedy but I saw
weird acts broke
coming up and I'm not surprised like
when I see a weird act this guy was like
a guy doing stand-up comedy wearing a
big tube oh wow and and of course you
can get really close with I'm sorry did
you know did you ever do any there's
NACA conventions there one okay no book
by zero colleges yeah nice to be wearing
a ticket I gave mine so I Josh wolf
I I did once I know Josh wolf I did one
in Sacramento in the early 90s and I
didn't get any either
and it was it you know big time in
California especially before the rest of
the United States a lot of universities
were demanding you know like ethnic
studies and things like that you know so
it was really popular topic at that time
and I followed this Colombian harp
player and this guy was [ __ ]
mesmerizing I swear to Jesus because I
bought three of his CDs I still I still
I still had this is over 25 years ago
and I still have it and I'll still put
it on every once in a while and this guy
tore the room apart and he's whatever
year you got to do a 20-minute set he
does like five minutes
bling-bling and he says my name is
Daniel Ortega Ortiz and I am from
Colombia and my hop is from Peru if you
are looking for a multicultural act I am
him I'm lying and I'm telling you like
these kids were [ __ ] lined up to get
this guy's like card or whatever it was
and then like I walk out there hey my
ball sack you were looking for a half
Argentinian history of Florida I did
Manion Orlando I know what comedy club
what those who the seed like over there
back then I love comedy clubs no bunkers
the club I started out years later
morphed into what became bunkers but it
was originally called the funny farm
and just some local Orlando comedians
started this and then they changed that
club to the very unfortunate title of
the Copa banana I still think is one of
the worst names for a company clubs ever
meet and then yeah there were there were
you know there was like a club in Tampa
Club in Miami but it was it was a lot of
rough one-nighters around
that's I started out but Brian Regan was
down there I'm in Freiburg Hedberg came
many many years later many years later
like a baby about ten years later had
Berg started when I met Hedberg like
early 90s in San Francisco after he had
left Florida but it was great Brian
Regan was there I remember playing like
tough biker bars in Daytona Beach with
him and he was always did clean material
like Jim Breuer was in Tampa Billy
Gardell started in Orlando
Ron Bennington was in Clearwater there's
a lot of there was some really great
comedians then I mean you know doing
rough shitty one-nighters but like the
boom the first what was funny because
like a lot of the the touring accident
we would show up in Florida because
we're like all starting out and
everybody's you know you're trying to
figure out how to be open Yeah right
so a lot of the the touring acts it came
to Florida where guys from New York City
and they wouldn't change their act they
had come to Florida and they're doing
their hey you know I'm on the subway you
know the subway you know when you're on
the subway yeah and like we're like you
know couldn't you have at least altered
that first twenty seconds of the bit so
we could relate to it given the
Washington Heights guy named Louie oh
Christ I lived in Washington nights when
I was 20 it was uh one of the one of the
worst years of my life Florida New York
yeah I thought I was ready to be too I
thought I was ready for the big time and
III could only afford to live in
Washington Heights and it was 1987 as
crack was coming to the neighborhood and
on Cabrini Boulevard where I lived every
morning there would be smoldering
burned-out cars it was a popular thing
for people to steal cars and lower
Manhattan and then drive him to
Washington Heights and so it was like
there's like a [ __ ] paper route or
something you know it's like you're
gunshots at night in the neighborhood
and then in the morning there's like
burning smoldering cars and and I
couldn't get sets at the good clubs and
I just don't like open mic nights and
you know but I it was interesting
because I always swore it was such a
tough year I always swore if I ever had
any money I'd live in New York City with
style so after I had my sitcom in 96 97
I had a ton of cash and I moved in I
moved to the Wall Street area 98 99
Hedberg was living at the Chelsea Hotel
and I was in The Wall Street area and we
were just it was a lot of I mean it was
a fun period but there's a lot of hard
narcotics what happened in was tonight
is just more crack no no I was only a
week I was only a weed smoker then and
I'm never way back there well I'll tell
you I don't know you guys are probably
too young to remember the great weed
drought of 1987 but I am Rock reservoir
dogs that when they were spraying
paraquat on that [ __ ] I was like nothing
and I was like so struggling in my life
and I was I was I was lonely I don't
have any friends and a roach nowhere and
I met this guy on the street and he
probably my last like $20 I probably had
just enough money I got this bag a weed
home and I got you know got back to my
apartment finally might have some relief
I open up this bag and it was like
leaves and oregano and I spent the rest
of that evening trying to cut my head
off with a steak knife
[Laughter]
getting no beefs is worse they getting
less weed then he put the pay for it you
know everyone Adam Murray this comedian
from Orlando you know that he works with
us Cody here I know I go to our house to
go to a house to get weed and he comes
out running and he comes in a car and he
opens it oh man we're driving away I
think I got hoes you know why would you
mean what does that mean good thing she
gave me less whoo
you pay for it it was here at 50 how
much to give you let me see
whoa it was like almost a gram almost
grabbed well yeah yeah point eight for
$50 are you friends with Adam Maria on
Facebook yeah okay this is my impression
of Eddie Murphy's Facebook oh my god I
just got back from the convenience store
and had the greatest career break I met
a guy at the Slurpee machine a movie
producer oh my god latest break-in show
come on mate he's a little kid for
Christmas hey guys and the guy turns out
he knows my dad he's gonna change his
oil form he was in it was in LA last
year and I saw him at the comedy store
and I'm talking him on the sidewalk out
front and this this homeless guy comes
up and I was talking to Adam for a
couple minutes and you know he's from
Orlando I'm being nice to the guy he's a
good dude comes up any he goes hey you
are in luck this is the most generous
guy in Hollywood and I just walked off
and left him with the guy and then Adams
Facebook post and everything was that I
met a homeless guy who's gonna get me on
The Tonight Show
you know he said I run into Tom roads
and I was part of a joke they play
there's a homeless guy awesome tomorrow
I'm gonna meet the guy to do the
warm-ups for the corn abrasion this fool
told me a funny a story so yeah so
Carlin gave me his number in Orlando
he's owning that I'm ever in town to
call him so what happened when you went
to LA well I go there and I called him
did he call you back
no he never answered funny bad I think
it was the anniversary of the cab driver
Fred they got killed with him
and then he put it in man I did a comedy
I did a comedy show with a guy who
killed my friend
yes the guy that killed his friend the
cab drivers who'll go around shooting
people was the waiter or a way stab at a
comedy played for 14 hey so crazy her
life is the guy they just heard my
drinks killed my friend in the right now
we're right in the movie together came
full circle the kid in Bad Santa is a
good funny like I was gonna hey guys I
gonna quit my acting class but then the
teacher put me to set me up with a hot
chick for a makeup scene so I say no for
six more months that's how they get you
though whenever you say you're gonna say
are you gonna quit the acting class hang
on let's pair where's vivianne
the fight is chick in the class and I'm
staying for six more months bunny work
with you man until his podcast actually
last week Nick gear up oh yeah I thought
that was hilarious man if you got
working together cuz hair long hair and
you had long hair yeah it was like
father and son almost yeah my wife calls
him the young Tom Rhodes
[Laughter]
yeah you know I love Nick and you know
what to see that guy grow as a comedian
and he's a beast
now but I worked with him in in Corpus
Christi years ago my god John woman is
this tiny whatever the clubs been there
for years and the guy it was kind of
[ __ ] up because you know I wanted to
go there I had never been there and I
did Houston every year so I contacted
the guy and then he was hesitant and he
said we only booked Latino acts here and
I said well I'm half Argentinian I don't
know if that makes any difference
I go by my mother's from Buenos Aires so
I go there and Nick opened and I had
never met him before and then the place
was empty
and then the guy and the guy the owner
guys like kind of you know I told you
like you know if you know how to latino
act they see the name they're not coming
and I said well you could have put
Rodriguez or something for my last name
I mean you could have put half
Argentinian on the on the on the bill
Argentinian I had to do I had to do the
morning radio show the next day and and
I had just met Nick and the owner I
thought was giving me kind of some
unnecessary grief for the place being
empty and I knew that the people at the
radio station didn't know what Tom roads
look like so I had Nick go for me and
say he was Tom Rhodes and I got to sleep
late and it was Nick's first radio thing
he goes and so he's like really young
and enthusiastic and I go dude would you
do this for me they don't know what time
looks like you oh my god I'd love to he
said he was Tom Rhodes and went in and
did my spot for me yeah I remember so I
will forever love that kid
I remember reading that Nick's on
myspace pulled that day yeah man
good morning ahead awake McCord wake-up
call then I have a continental breakfast
MySpace Wow you know where my spice went
wrong the ranking your friends top 20
sightseers wanted to be my the top one
they made you rank your friends that's
where that man that ruined a lot of
relationships yeah yeah later
I remember them statin one was when
women who had our men that were in
prison locked up they had a little
countdown with glitter oh my god like it
was counted five years 38 hours
that's how long you had to I don't know
what Clem you're talking about you're
talking about the comedy club that was
in the side of the Marla loot that they
were gonna demolished in Corpus Christi
yeah it was like uh it was like the end
of the Marlboro like Panther sensual or
they're broke
yeah it would like that part of the mall
was cut off on the raise another mall
you couldn't walk to that comedy club
from inside the mall he's gonna go
outside and then walk outside the mall
and then get to the comedy club yeah the
place is empty I said tell him I'm half
Argentinian the problem was my fault
it's funny the name the corpse of Christ
corporate cries yeah nice place
I've been down they have another comedy
club they're called the Mesquite right
yeah mesquite Street mesquite Street
it's a pizza place and then they started
a comedy club
that's like attached yeah they were
coming Club upstairs that seats 150 I
don't want to see 200 people up there
man
the roof is gonna collapse what hotel
you stay at the rodeo stood at the worst
hotel in Corpus Bayfront in yep that was
it Roach's back then too it was pretty
gritty turned on his hair bro driver and
a rose flew out usually you have to pay
extra for that
the most saddest Beach yeah I you know
what I didn't I kind of I guess I was in
and out you know I wanted to go to that
I've always wanted to go down to the
farthest reaches of Texas like
Brownsville and all that we got robbed a
Bronco by the way we're performing on
showing the theater somebody broke into
the green room and took my laptop oh no
my tennis shoes I took my friend's car
keys to go his jokes with that there's a
guy down there get off the feet I'm
sorry I brought it up by the border so
then you moved out to San Francisco
yeah Wow you uh yeah I moved well I
moved so I moved to New York for a year
when I was 20 and I wasn't ready and it
was difficult so I moved back to Florida
and licked my wounds for a year and then
I moved to San Francisco and then that's
where like I really started to get good
that's where I came together for me well
clothes we performed the punch line was
cobs when I was at the Fisherman's Wharf
the old Cobbs
Tom at ease Tommy T's man San Leandro
conquered there was three of them back
yeah edited yeah I still go there yeah
yeah and then there was the improv and
uh downtown as well god it was a ton of
work there
San Jose Joe the second one a punch
light used to have a sign with a punch
line I could be wrong
no there was one in Walnut Creek Walnut
Creek and then Sacramento and then
before the improv I don't think there
was anything and that's the limited I
think in San Jose Sacramento sacrament
downtown yeah so we did all those clubs
all them clubs
yeah not work huh yeah it was great and
then you know I I just thought it
California was a magic Candyland
you know it was everything left-wing
utopian ideal and my favorite kind of
audiences are multi-ethnic multinational
and
you know I wanted the guy started out on
the southern circuits and the South
wanted to get away from the rednecks and
then I could do smarter material and I
really flourished as a president being
and a comedian and then that's where I
got the attention of you know Comedy
Central and then started to do on
television when you got your development
dude that happened in LA or better Cisco
yeah I got to draw you I did two drink
minimum
I remember that I mean I was a comedy
central yeah yeah yeah we took minimum
and then after that with the Pepsi the
Dorito perhaps the carbon was 20
yeah that was like that thing I've
always had that kind of that level show
were there break in new talent but
they've changed the name of it like
three four times but I did that and a
woman named Laurie Zak's it was his
executive at Comedy Central they that's
when I got this development deal I got
to film these these they filmed my jokes
like rock videos little interstitials
things like Denis Leary did for MTV
years ago remember those things then
they had me do those and then they sent
me to cover the dream team the Super
Bowl all these things and then I got to
make an hour special where I went to
Vietnam called Viva Vietnam so and then
that's where you know I started getting
popular do you have the Tom road show
you're a teacher yeah mr. Rhodes on NBC
yeah ie I was like kind of the face of
Comedy Central for two years and then
NBC discovered me but I mean I was
already given a lot of comedians
development deals a lot of but there
were all his teachers are home with the
Cooper one too yeah there was that Reno
yeah there was that year you know my
original idea I wanted to be a public
defender lawyer oh the voice of the
voiceless to give us a quick thought I'd
get my well it was Gerardo had a a solo
his show failed and then another lower
Boston Common common law common law
something like that and then and then
NBC he had a lawyer show also fail so
then they said can you make Tom a
teacher and at that time I was pretty
young
arrogant I thought if I can be a [ __ ]
garbage man kick-ass job don't matter
baby it's Tom Rhodes is what's the funny
and in retrospect somebody knew that
year that was like five teacher shows
came on yeah at that one year and then
it was like oh [ __ ] why did we go with
the teacher idea but somebody but it was
like and it was kind of [ __ ] up to man
because they wouldn't give me jokes I
mean my wife you mean items my wife told
me I can she doesn't allow me to talk
bad about that experience cuz she said
you had your own sitcom and you named
after it but I mean it was they you know
gave me nice advice to for the kids and
I didn't get many jokes and there was
like a funny kid around me and everybody
else is like Tom I had long hair so
they're all making how Bob Saget
basically has a teacher they so I had a
really long hair and so every joke was
hey Fabio hey creep Prince
hey Kenny G and then they wouldn't let
me say anything back and I would go talk
to them I would go talk to the executive
producer and I'd say anybody I've ever
considered a hero couldn't be topped
like if you say something snarky the
hero crushes them like a bug and that's
what I do in the club
somebody heckled you crush him like a
bug I go look you you just say in the
script it says Tom reacts how many times
can somebody say something shitty to me
and then I just shrunk well that's not
someone I would consider a hero
they wouldn't I didn't have any adult
friendships on the show I I just like
was friends with the kids and I told the
executive producer anyone like that in
real life I think should be closely
monitored my wife's not gonna hear this
cuz she's like I told you never to say
anything bad what would they tell you
when you would say that it was our our
marketing studies show that the audience
doesn't like when you come back and say
something nasty to someone that's what
David Goodis showed earlier home being a
dog without your commute
your friend playing poker hey Bernie Mac
yeah a little bit cool I mean you know
he was shown you doing I'm correcting
homework at a ballgame the guy seemed
teachers do that yes a shitload teacher
a ball game collecting paper and
watching the baseball game yeah it would
have been more like pretty cool man yeah
that won't teachers do yeah and then
also in the original script was and the
original pilot was I had a cousin who
was a bartender and so I would go like
talk to him every mother
how many bartender we had so I but and
but that was cut out and then also me
doing stand-up in the class was gonna be
another thing that was cut out so I mean
you know I'm blessed as [ __ ] because I
got to have my own show and that money
you know I had always been in a
struggling comedian up to that point and
I for a few years I had a ton of cash
lived on top of the Hollywood Hills at a
apartment it was all glass window glass
walls I lived with a beautiful actress
and all we did was walk around naked
drinking wine from goblets and then when
the show and when the show finished I
looked at that money as my NBC artist
grant so I moved back to New York City
just focused on stand-up and you know
I'm doing the the Comedy Cellar and all
this club's hardcore but also I started
with that money I invested in myself to
take trips to London and then I got him
with London over you know I it was it
took me about two or three trips to get
in solid to get paid booked to work and
then once I got him with London that led
to gigs around Europe and the rest of
the world and all the international
circuits that I've been doing for the
last 20 years so it really was I
shouldn't complain that much about it
because it did help me catapult myself
into a better life you then little show
like your own talk show right and after
them
yeah I come or somebody I would ask
about you like two comedians and yeah Oh
max come on man you know whether an
answer that he's let him in over there
yeah I I had moved to Amsterdam my wife
is from Holland but I original
from Harlan well [ __ ] you from yeah my
wife is from Rotterdam my way it's
interesting my water down my wife is her
ethnicity is Indian but she's from
Suriname which was a Dutch colony at the
top of South America a lot of people
don't know my Argentina my argentinian
relatives in argentina they they don't
even know where so they've never even
heard a surname it's on the same
continent how can you not know all the
countries anyway but a lot of people
don't realize there's a Dutch speaking
country in South America go Jana - right
they speak Dutch no Guyana is French
Guyana and English Guyana and then CERN
em so those European colonial powers so
that was it that at the top of South
America run from first ships going
around the world that was a strategical
place for ships this time didn't make it
there well those people also that's
remember that gang the one about the
gangs in Rotterdam and biker games
actually there are affiliates of the
Crips right yeah remember it was Crips
and those guys are from Suriname - and
yeah it's a Dutch column I did a show in
Rotterdam called Romani I'm in his life
I've done it I'm Raymond is from Sur now
yeah he gave me a bottle of rum oh nice
yeah he does that character on that show
where he dresses up like an old woman
sitting on the porch that's because it's
a very like Caribbean tropical style
they're the people you know that's also
on he's doing like he's even become like
bigger he's kind of like the Oprah now
so he doesn't do that late-night talk
show anymore he does more of like this
kind of Oprah program another thing
we're not doing his show he live but um
you love to say [ __ ] on that television
yeah I [ __ ] up your name but I'll
[ __ ] say it again hold on okay all
right we're back huh Felipe Esparza our
focus today right Felipe Esparza but
ever we are well they're telling me to
be clean yeah it's interesting thing
because it's amazing I was on Dutch I
was on Dutch television
for three years and the censorship in
Holland is you can say anything you can
show anything
the only censorship is you are not
allowed to endorse products you can say
you like beer but you can't say you like
Heineken because that's endorsing a
specific brand I had steve-o from
jackass on the show on the when they
when the first Jackass movie came out
and he can't believe there's no
censorship on Dutch oven you come out
smoking a joint
Amsterdam really man there's no
censorship on Dutch television I'm like
yeah so he waves down his pants and he
asked for a stapler somebody brought him
a stapler I mean it took like ten
minutes but TV editing booms two seconds
later he spreads his nutsack across his
thigh and stapled his ball sack to his
leg and blood spurted and you could see
the little metal prong holding his
nutsack his thigh and Dutch television
they got a close-up of it you know and I
used to have it on YouTube but YouTube
made me take it down but but that's
Dutch television you can show anything
you can say anything it's it's almost
the exact opposite of our censorship
because in our culture it's all about I
love Heineken and I love [ __ ]
products and you can't say all these
different things and you can't you know
yeah my god there was a soap commercial
with a naked woman they showed of
breasts and of course a woman in a
shower of course you're gonna you're
naked when you're using soap in the
shower of why can't you show a woman
soap and offer both a perfect example
here in America gonna be jealous and
Irish guy Irish Spring yeah we will be
cutting over the guy he would be cutting
the soap cutter stolen world bro so what
I was gonna say wow manly to be on that
TV I moved to Amsterdam for a Dutch girl
that I had fallen in love with not my
wife and then I was doing the focus and
I was doing Europe and doing these
international circuits and then that
girl broke up with me and I was just
about to move back to the United States
when these people from this Dutch
television
work we're looking for an American to
host a late night show and then I got
the job
and so I got to stay in this little
country that I had fallen in love with
how many years so I did the late I
talked you up for two years and it was
awesome that my the big part of the show
was I was a I was a foreigner
experiencing Dutch culture so every
episode that we would make like a
five-minute film of me experiencing
something of Dutch culture I spent a day
with a Dutch farmer walked into an
electric fence
the guy said look out for the electric
fence in Dutch but I don't speak Dutch I
got electrocuted they thought it was
hilarious
I got to go to the Prime Minister
debates with a press pass on the floor
they would also also explain all the
laws to me everything about Dutch
culture a politician a right-wing
Christian stoner guy who owned a coffee
shop explained the drug laws to me took
me around to the coffee shops a former
prostitute who helps the women get their
health care and do their taxes and these
this really benevolent foreign former
prostitute gave me a tour of the red
light district explained to me the whole
how they tax how they stay healthy and
and all this stuff like every element of
Dutch culture was explained to me it was
really like having a magic passport to
this country and I really I love Holland
there was a time where Tenacious D and
Jack Black came that's on YouTube where
I showed them around Amsterdam just you
know smoking pot and showing him the
city and did a lot of really beautiful
things and then when that show ended the
same network let me be a presenter on a
Travel Show for a year so I filmed a
highlight on Peru still my favourite
trip I've ever taken in my life I'll be
rooting for Peru in the World Cup I did
a highlight on st. Petersburg Russia on
the Dutch Caribbean France I died you
got to do so many cool things but I'd
like a nice three-year run and I don't
speak Dutch that's remarkable that I had
this mattress big weed
yeah but Dutch people hate weed and
really you can ask my wife they get
tired of people were asking where the
coffee shop well it's like they
marijuana is legal but they teach their
children that drugs are for losers and
so my wife's worse huh they say if you
smoke pot over they say that weed is for
teenagers and tourists and if you're
over 30 and you still smoke pot in
Holland they consider you very immature
so this has been something that I your
wife looks down on you she's like I'm
telling you she's like she's an iron
fist which is good because I used to be
a huge stoner and now I get a lot of
[ __ ] done I've been writing up I wrote
the first draft of a book I'm trying to
get that it's my life traveling the
world and all these you know things that
have happened to me you know I got maced
in Paris I almost drowned in Thailand I
got all these stories about you know the
show and just anyway I've been able to
focus on this book because my wife will
let me smoke pot only a handful of times
a month once I start telling a long
story with a lot of pause dead giveaway
how the weed over there compared to over
here with the first time you went on I
like it I tell you and my opinion the
best weed is outdoor Northern California
weed that Humboldt County Mendocino up
there do them so that one in Holland
it's all and Holland's all the indoor
greenhouse stuff and then it's always
like Super Skunk xxx whatever and when
Americans go there first it's always
like give me the Super Skunk xxx but
after I lived there for five years after
you're there for like a year you're like
you guys don't have any like happy
Mexican joint rolling we do you that's
like that's the best weed in the world
where you can still function and that
glow in the dark green [ __ ] where you're
hitting it like a crack pipe [ __ ] that
where you got over you where you're
experiencing polio for the length of
your high
you're on the couch you can't lift your
arm just like [ __ ] that
I want like I want some happy pass a
joint let's all think of jokes and
stories we've you know that's good
that's the best kind a back would I know
that what she got another room when I
was there after them I did like if they
have good hash that's about it
- yeah yeah [ __ ] hash drawer like
some sticky [ __ ] bro that I could just
roll up in one single line and put on
the whole blood I had that I had the
powder Keefe more than one of the best
has ever had with over there
yeah cuz everybody keeps your brain kind
clear where you're high but you're not
like all yeah yeah man we had a good
hash never dude like real bomb ass like
Moroccan hashes I'm like that never I
just heard stories about it though I
mean you know it's like somebody oh you
know pop some you know a joint whatever
y'all it intensifies it or whatever but
nothing like blew my socks off Tina
borrow their bikes locked up in that
cage that's a whose [ __ ] bikes are
these in I mean when I was high and
Rotterdam I always play where people
keep their bicycles yeah and then we're
all locked up inside like a [ __ ]
bikes there who [ __ ] bikes are these
in front of Central Station at most you
must have been by the train station
yeah that's Central Station and then the
Central Station in Amsterdam there's a
bike parking garage and it's like five
levels yeah and when I lived there I
would always park my bike up on the top
and then because it was great because
you could get on the top and you could
coast all the way down if you like did
your balance right on the turns and it
was really fun and the thing in
Amsterdam is the junkies steal the bikes
and there's this big thing of junkies
stealing bikes and selling them for like
five ten dollars and when I first lived
there I thought I'm not gonna support
that and then after you've after you've
had like five or six bikes stolen that
you've paid fifty seventy-five dollars
for then it's like yeah I'll take a five
dollar jump junky bike see whenever
you're in Amsterdam you see a guy on a
bike pedaling any
has another bike in his hand that he's
riding beside him stole that is a stolen
junky bike and that guy is looking to
sell that bike for five or ten dollars
so he can get a fix
good to know next travel tip yeah okay
you want another travel tip about where
to friend bring online where to find
weed or hash when traveling in Europe
okay so if you're in Europe and babe
Spain Spain especially yes this this tip
I learned in in Spain in Sevilla yeah go
to the main square of any town or city
in Europe and there will be a statue
just go hang out by the statue for a
little bit and some type of kind
friendly immigrant person usually of
Moroccan descent will come up and ask
[Laughter]
heroin did you really oh yeah yeah where
did you find heroin oh man I got man
it's funny I was there with somebody and
then I disappeared I got drunk and I
just went on my own way you know the
Rotterdam I don't know I want you are
[ __ ] up you were Amsterdam and you
ended up an hour I was in Rotterdam that
was I was stained and I remember going
to this bar and one thing but black
people inside I don't know where I was I
felt that wasn't Oakland or something
but I felt at home in there I was in
there man sitting down there's an old
man singing in the jukebox song if
loving you and right I don't want to be
wrong so then I spent that one night
sitting there about four people were
drinking a bar so there was only four
people there then after everybody got
comfortable I said man we couldn't get
some coke ha ha there's a girl gave me
coke but it was crack but that's hip but
I know bro
super definitely walking I met another
guy with long hair and he took me to a
house with these two hookers it was
weird bro two hookers they were nasty
bro
but just wanting to do coke we look
through the houses when we get there
the food takes all his clothes off bro
like immediately in origin immediately
bro like a natholi bro NBA player bro
just takes all his Willie Barcena bro
took all his clothes off then a girls
goes hey hey hey hey then I say yeah man
we get hyper so there now we the guy was
making his crack right there was dumb
some kind of gas or something like that
powder and they mix it up and then he'll
give me the crack there's some guy
showed up Meraki looking guys and there
was the offer of heroin we bought it so
you knew it was heroin but you were out
of crack and coke correctly oh yeah Oh
balance it out and this was in Rotterdam
ranch Rotterdam yeah a lot of people
realize it Rotterdam is the most
ethnically diverse city in Europe they
were calling me East LA for mr. Lee yeah
they had all little scene blood and
blood they all see blood in blood out
some movie here in America like a
gangster movie American me and throw a
ton of him Eastern Lane it's just like
they like me because the movie they saw
you knows in them I was like yeah my
hometown so let me write and then
Rotterdam knowing dip there's this like
real hip-hop style they try and be like
New York and they they they love kind of
Brooklyn East LA kind of culture they
kind of consider themselves to be like
tougher like people in Rotterdam and
what's up with uh what's up with heroin
how do you smoke that you add it to
tobacco or something or I've never done
it no but you looked at me give me a
straw and aluminum foil oh you hot
really and then I put the black rocks
right there then it somebody light it
the girl lady for me and it go just just
so gonna smoke me so that suck on this
moment
so I snuck in a smoke bro I took a bunch
of waves it turned off immediately I
felt like my whole my whole insides got
turned out like it like somebody took my
body showed it to me and put it back in
and then I felt like I just came off a
super merry-go-round and I went straight
to a toy I threw up no that's what I did
everything but heroin and when I was
partying and I was always afraid of
heroin and the thing that I was heard
about heroin is that like you vomit at
the beginning and like I think that was
what killed it for me yeah Robert wants
to do anything where you got a vomit
before you feel good I vomit I remember
just sitting there and then like
somebody made me some tea and I thought
oh that's the best tea ever probably
haven't eaten all day but no the best
tea ever but then I keep smoking more
heroin and then I just don't smoke all
the money I made from Raymond is locked
ha ha ha that was a good gig IIe I did
that show myself I got booked at
Montreal by a guy from Rotterdam some
some guy with long hair Marcel Marcel
yes he was looking for me all night
Marcel how good or sell any book to him
in his life he's still around
yeah and he does the Rotterdam Comedy
Festival now my mom ready brother are
you sober yeah yeah me too me Rosie
already bloody know what's the full
podcast of Rotterdam same I busted my
head open in Philadelphia four years ago
see this well see the scar yeah I
blacked out and fell off of a barstool
Oh
so yeah I got six stitches it's busted
busted my head open so I don't like
drinking and fell like a tree blacked
out from drinking wouldn't treat a man I
had 10 pints of Sierra Nevada which was
by all accounts a very normal evening I
was a very normal guys our Big Buddha
bottle right yeah and that's how I
blacked out felt like a tree off the
barstool bus in my head and this guy
lifts me up and he and I'm
I'm looking down there's blood
everywhere okay we gotta call an
ambulance yells out to the bar I go [ __ ]
that I don't have health insurance
don't you dare call you got to get to a
hospital
how far is the nearest hospital it was
two blocks two blocks and you were gonna
call an ambulance I was like $15,000 you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I got I got a wad of
napkins off the bar and I walked to the
hospital like you know badass there's
great man I felt and I got six stitches
on my forehead and I felt like you got
you kind of feel like you know getting
your forehead stitches aren't good the
one bad but I had also cut open the top
of my head and they can't stitch on the
top staples you think I do the staple
hey I got five staples on the on the top
of my head and that chunk twice yeah the
stitches are number six
Steve okay try your balls yeah Knightly
Knightly is your clothes are Tommy Tito
committee at Steven state house they
doesn't every night if you have two
shows to Staples yeah
so I haven't I haven't Wow I don't drink
or done drugs since then since that
night oh yeah yeah just you know just a
little pot with my wife Alice so you got
to make crack cool no no no I want to
i-i've just you know a couple years 98
99 2000 I enjoyed some cocaine but for
the older listeners
that was really great period for ecstasy
I was really out dancing and doing
ecstasy and really Wow
Julianne life and Europe yeah and in New
York New York City and Europe I was
first starting to go to Europe and then
and then I was never officially so doing
ecstasy Rotterdam that's like a freak
bro an Amsterdam especially in London
you know it was a lot of
I mean I think I think it's still like
the 1980s in London everybody's got coke
in London you know but and then I was
never an acid guy but I remember a
friend of mine gave me a bunch of pure
LSD on sugar cubes like maybe about ten
ago and that was pretty wonderful so you
like me you pretty much done anything
when you're buzzed yeah I'm glad we we
didn't hang out people gathering me back
there man you joy Coco yeah Ashley
Ashley Hamilton that's right no party
I've never done I don't know one no
twice it was great but it lasts too long
yeah the next day yeah that was the good
thing about the pure stuff you didn't
have that feeling because I lived in the
Wall Street area Gold Street right there
by Fulton Street oh wow we probably
drank at some of the same little dive
bars I went to John Street bar the one
the biker bar they forget to name it I
walked by there there was a there was an
old Irish pub that looked like it was
from the 1880s and it was dank and it
was all these Wall Street guys being
there like doing coke and like it was a
really dark seedy place it was some
really cool bars down there but the
great thing it was before September 11
oh you think so
all of lower Manhattan was like it felt
like living in Gotham I felt like Batman
like I'd go home nobody's down there the
streets yeah and so I one thing I really
enjoyed doing especially those times I
did the pure LSD on the sugar cubes was
rollerblading around lower Manhattan so
I'd like to some drink some tea with my
pure LSD on the sugar cube and then I
put my I get my walkman you know I'd get
it you know cassette and just skate
around lower Manhattan
you know do you know do little figure
eights in the World Trade Center around
the you know it was great there was
nobody down there you'd see like one
security guard walking around the World
Trade Center the downside was that when
when 9/11 happened there wasn't much
information for people who lived down
there because they weren't used to
people really living down there like
there it was dotted with a few apartment
buildings like but you know it was
mostly businesses so there wasn't a lot
of information for like what to do I'm
glad you bring that up I lived at
there's a 71 Broadway excuse me it was
considered one of the first skyscrapers
ever built and the 1890s something like
that and it was only 20 storeys tall and
only on the 18th this is what I did with
my sitcom money only on the 18th floor
they had these marble balconies and I
was on the corner at his balcony and
then so I actually looked up at the
World Trade Center and then looking down
Trinity Church is right next to ya so
that that's right where's doors the
entrance of I looked I looked down on on
Trinity Church and so the Trinity Church
is like is right at the entrance of Wall
Street so this girl who grew up in my
neighborhood who I went to high school
with
it was great friends with and I didn't
see her until about 10 years ago and I
talked to her and she was like she lived
in New York at the same time I did and
we're talking further and then oh my god
she lived in my same building I moved
out January 1st 2000 and then I moved to
Amsterdam I just do everything the
storage [ __ ] off to Europe and then it
turned out my friend's childhood great
friend she lived in this building at the
same time I did and she lived there for
September 11th and she so I'm like wow
so what was that like in the lower
Manhattan she said I was terrible you
know that was barricaded and there's
soldiers tanks and tanks and police and
she goes she goes it was terrible
because I have I had three cats I had
two and I couldn't couldn't get the same
story so she goes she goes I kept
telling the guy gotta get back to my
apartment I've
cats I gotta take care of my cats and
they're like nah [ __ ] off get out of
here we're not no one's allowed down
there so she got the idea she went
around to a different section of
barricades and she went up to the cops
and said my dogs I have dogs I have two
and the cop said oh my god you have dogs
get right down there go so like so they
didn't give a [ __ ] about my rabbits yeah
so if you just said you had a dog they
would've liked this gas problem from
when seven collapsed and so they cut off
all the services that's amazing you
lived down there well all that all that
life all their life right then like boy
the bars in that area I was all gone
after 9/11 nobody hung out but there
wasn't much hanging out anyway there
were a couple dive bars and so did you
like go hang out in like Tribeca and the
Houston Street area you know it was
great because I would I would always end
my my Seth my I would do sets all night
and then you always end up at the Comedy
Cellar and you know and getting [ __ ]
up there and the Dave Attell drinking in
these great dive bars and you know [ __ ]
you would never find unless you were
with a serious alcoholic from New York
City like no matter how [ __ ] up by God
I would I would often walk home from the
Comedy Cellar to my place at 71 Broadway
and so you just go you know it's like
you know Soho and then there's Chinatown
and then it's you know Wall Street and
so the World Trade Center no matter how
[ __ ] up I was all I had did you find
the World Trade Center and just head in
that direction so there was another
thing about I took a few girls on dates
to the top of the World Trade Center and
there the restaurant was super expensive
but there was a bar up there which also
was expensive but it was a great date
and then a few blocks later short walk
over
my apartment were on my 18th floor
balconies sipping wine looking up at the
greatest date ever and I remember when
September 11th happened in spite of all
the tragedy and everything else I
thought oh man they ruined the greatest
date to take a woman that was the
greatest date to take a girl to the top
of the World Trade Center it's funny I I
used to wait tables in New York and I
always wanted a job at windows on the
world I that was and they had like the
top some wine Somalis in the world some
of them worked there and it was just it
was really hard to get a job there but
you could make a ton of cash there pints
with $10 it was expensive when you were
runner down again free health care no no
no you're American no because I paid
taxes in America and I didn't you still
have to pay taxes for the money earned
over there that's the American Way baby
Wow nothing but when I opened up for
Russell Peter in Canada I had to pay
taxes in Canada and America yep I made
nothing I saw the video you on the on
his little private jet
yeah yeah with da Mira it's a TV show he
did you were on I think 11 days out of
that yeah it's fine man yeah you look
like you're like way up on the top of
the globe it's funny woman ever get Ken
and I sound like you know here in LA
with a lot of taco trucks a lot of
shwarma shwarma up the swarm ah chicken
shawarma yeah was so full or 0 which is
dates huh what's your next date with me
next show I don't have anything going on
here just the dates you have on the
Yemma
yeah we have a new episode out so that
came out yesterday so please check it
out dates again Tom Rose people go check
him out I
January 29th I'm in Paris France at the
théâtre de louvre and then one shows
February 7 through 10 I'm at the
punchline in San Francisco February 23
to 25 I'm at side splitters in Tampa and
I have a brand new album on I
toons called all hail laughter and I
have a charming little podcast also on
the all things comedy Network called Tom
Rhodes radio SmartCamp I've seen that
I've seen a podcast on the top 200
iTunes what's up fool give us a thumb
rule joke yeah Tom I want your own here
both you guys do he had a cool-ass joke
there Oh what's uh what the city has the
most beautiful woman the world is it
Amsterdam you just lights yeah I think I
know the joke yeah I mean these women
are great I always have to I was good uh
the UK to rest my eyes Holland holiday
as to why I'd have a girlfriend named
summer who was a stripper her stripper
name was jam I know a girl named Sierra
yes stripper name is Jill first time we
met we met and I was little star-struck
of course every time I meet a legend
without you it was that the that's a Joe
Diaz show at the Brea improv and Joe
Rogan showed up and we're blazing it
with him oh my god Joe your father was
there you were wearing the [ __ ] now
the talk the Roadshow sweatshirt that's
around you mr. red sweatshirt yeah yeah
yeah and um you get the solo pilot oh
yeah yeah my dad
yeah I loved my dad my dad's the reason
I'm a comedian and also that's cool that
you bring that up by the other reason
about coming into a man did everything
he do I'm gonna do everything so no
party so below negative to protecting
either way
what's up fool Torres right here Lisa
right here Alex DeLarge for giving us a
heads up your whole set in Salinas
where's the security
my Denton assistant did the whole team
to one of my the girl that asked for the
phone at my dental office I invited to
the show she putting it in so I love the
show I recorded the whole show of my
phone really what this guy shout-out to
Chris Rodriguez at 13-13 I want to want
to know something funny I was the guy
just show years ago at the Lobo LA you
clown me like for 10 minutes got that
[ __ ] recorded before your wife made us
turn it off you clowned us why I haven't
been why I haven't married my girlfriend
we've been together 17 years that must
have been the straw that broke the
camel's back because we broke up in
August you [ __ ] homewrecker she just
shined a light under the prompter for 17
years and I remember I remember I said
17 years and I said you read the word
[ __ ] walk out of their relationship is
the wake-up call crowd you were her
Oprah yeah man turn the lights on for
her Tom Rhodes people check out the Tom
Rose podcast yeah and the yeah men and
everything on all things comedy thank
you for my bag hell yeah
that's right